so we're here again with Paul Paul why
is it important to have interactivity in
your prototypes so it's important to
have interactivity in your prototypes
because one thing that I often see in
demos or in presentations is that I want
to say hey here's my prototype and
unfortunately this doesn't give you a
really good understanding of how
somebody's actually gonna use your
prototype I'm not the user you are not
your user right and so if i use this
prototype and i am an expert in it i can
I know how to get good results right if
I do this and the birthday of this and
you right and you can actually use it
and play with it and interact with it
you have never seen this before right so
you're going to be a much better
representation of how an end user is
actually going to use this right all
right the other thing if there's really
nobody else around what you can do is
get really drunk and then use your
prototype and that's going to be
actually a fairly good approximation
about the random person on the internet
losing your device or using your website
they're actually a few different
services that you can go online and find
where you will have a usability expert
get drunk and review your usability and
send you a report on it awesome thank
you Paul welcome